hello everybody and welcome back to the
amnesia custom story abduction wait
who's that handsome guy up in the corner
it me yeah finally got my webcam so you
guys can see my looks of horror as I go
into the guest room
alright oh nope never mind not going
into guest room what do we got a door
upstairs lock this is getting annoying
no kidding yeah alright whatever
bring on the scares all right I'm
guessing this big door app won't even
let me touch it
fine fine ah me master bedroom there we
go that's more like it
okay oh nice and bright finally some
appreciation for sunlight is what I'm
talking about
huh huija oh come here 10 newbucks Keith
gotcha library key okay but cannot wait
anymore and my soul is empty was it
something I said I did or said you know
love me blah blah he's he's back jeez
Helen get over it that piano music yeah
whatever whoever's playing piano you
can't sock I'm kidding hey great better
than I can play Vienna so I'm not gonna
criticize um
doesn't seem like anything here this
seems like a very peaceful room I know
that's probably a mistake it's probably
not a peaceful room at all and it's
probably a master bedroom of horror and
terrifying this okay was the library was
it down here um oh yeah yeah yeah okay
come here
good opened this was it wasn't it wasn't
it I don't know yep yep yep yep yep yep
okay all right thank you my oh stop
checking it's on a very flimsy so lots
of chairs
I like this just from his well accident
uninhabitable and complete disarray
doors been locked the key is now being
stored in third floor the library sounds
good to me under the third floor I go oh
man it's another super dark place
there's like tons of light but I can't
see a damn thing
Oh booyakasha good get out of y'all I
have proof proof that other worlds exist
all right could hear voices inside the
fume huh ran from the lab recreate the
phenomenon okay must be like Alexander's
first experiment or something there's a
lightning storm outside it's gonna
double creeped me out right now not that
I'm scared hot not scared at all so
brave obviously come on give it some oh
yeah I hate that picture it's everywhere
get out of here
ah oh why do I hit mannequin so much uh
hate him hate him hate him hate hate
hate uh
nothing in here uh nope to the box
anarchy Oh got you
I need a key to get to the third floor
that's weird
super dark okay out of here okay Oh what
is it with the pictures of Alexander
everywhere ah this is just silly okay
and if they're dorky third floor key get
out of here oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you buddy
[ __ ] you get out of here get out of here
daddy
uh [ __ ] scheisse huh
back off oh my good old friend the chair
I'm gonna get some where'd you go
did you just disappear did he just
disappear of course he did just drink
Oh whatever okay ran all the way
downstairs but I'm not letting go my
chair be sure that all right what do we
got here mmm-hmm
nothing nothing
oh this looks cornering Aki there we are
back off got chair narrow space no gimme
gimme
oh no it's glued to the floor uh okay
I'm fine
yeah how am i doing on oil anymore
good thing I got seven jugs of it oh
yeah uh okay moving on got the guest
room key and I'll go the guests from I'm
pretty sure the key to the laboratories
gonna be in the guest room and then I
can get out of here I don't know move on
whatever what ever man but seriously
this is a very involved mod lots of work
put into this one kudos to them all
right back up to the guest room
uh-huh did it buddy buddy gimme in there
okay moving forward okay oh thank
goodness finally have room the nice and
bright
oh it's for guests I am a guest in your
house thank you for recognizing me chair
I know it's super all the lights are
probably just gonna go out on me because
it is too nice here way too nice
um okay don't look so bad
ah oh oh oh hey those things oh hey you
hey you get out of here we're gonna do
now
nothing finally an appreciation for a
bright sunshiny day foolish old man he
doesn't realize I stole his key swallow
did I did how this happened did I do
this did I get drunk mousse man Oh get
out of you get out of here oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no don't come here don't
come here get away get away
Oh give me something
some oh no reason Oh get out of here oh
[ __ ] man okay I'm okay I'm okay
okay guys what did I get library I
didn't get anything
oh boy that notes a man swallowed an
important key oh it was the guy it was
it was the other room I gotta stab him
open with my dagger uh this dead guy
that guy
perhaps I could find him just laying up
with his junk please be gone mr. mousse
man don't come near me
hello just gonna do something here oh
yeah that was normal
Oh a lot of keys thank you I am out of
here
oh I'm so out here labora twerking oh I
gotta go back into the darkness ah
alright alright bring it on I'm tougher
than this okay
was it down here down here storage yeah
course it's in the storage where else
would it be
oh hoop it's a laboratory at the bottom
of the storage okay well thank you thank
you torches for still being lit up uh
okay there's nothing there's nothing
nothing hey cockroach how's it going
good buddy hi I move this I did y'all
saw oh yeah so strong yeah good don't
guy guy guy okay there's a all the boxes
you blew up but it's weird how things
just magically restock themselves you
know okay oh don't even further down huh
uh do not like this big shut up
lightning boxes epic deep Oh
I said epic okay that's cool oh I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you like the webcam if
you do let me know in the comments thumb
it up uh
whatever just let me know if you like
the webcam if you like seeing my
terrified reactions uh
and if you do I'll keep doing it thank
you guys so much for watching and I will
see you guys in the next part bye-bye